guest is an accomplished actor director
writer musician but did you know that
fun fact as a kid he actually wanted to
grow up to be a bathtub please welcome
human man David Duchovny
[Applause]
I have been so excited to talk to you
I'm so thrilled that you would come here
thank you oh it's my pleasure thank you
and thank you for adding me as a bathtub
wannabe I had no idea you aspired to be
a bathtub how and where and why I think
it's hard to get into the brain of a
six-year-old that I was but I think
probably bath time you have kids bath
time was my favorite time and I thought
if I was a bathtub then I'd be in my
favorite time all the time
well you heard it here first I feel very
lucky to be on this breaking I'm making
a change Drew I'm making a change
yeah um
I know this is a departure because we
have so many things to get into my
daughter and I have been reading your
book
um which is so fascinating oh thanks and
it's such an interesting story and it's
visually incredibly compelling when did
you decide to put this into the world
and then it's also about worlds plural
yes it is yeah
um it's it's taken about like four or
five years working with Philip sevy the
the illustrator but it was really there
were two kind of vectors that came
together for me hot God
I'll try to use that word again
but one was like for me a formative
moment was like in Planet of the Apes
when you realized that they were on
earth right the most incredible as a kid
it was just you know Charlton Heston at
Point Doom that I know now but but back
then it was just like blew my mind so
always I was like how can I ever come up
with the that kind of reverse you know
that kind of pull the rug out from an
audience and and I thought that I did
here you know with the kind of the
reverse of the planets you absolutely do
oh thanks okay another pivot that I have
to talk to you about because it's one of
my favorite episodes
um of Sex in the City when you and
Carrie who are like uh younger boyfriend
and girlfriend I mean come on boy
interrupted
thank you
yeah
I love that uh episode so much when you
show up with the sign and there's all
the romance of like if our have we all
wasted our time in life should we have
just gone with the origin story of who
we loved first yeah it's interesting
because uh this movie that I just
wrapped with Meg Ryan it's a very
similar kind of a setup which is where
we're too old like college lovers that
are stuck in an airport during a
blizzard and have to kind of relitigate
our whole our whole relationship so
you're into that that storyline so there
you go doesn't Meg Ryan direct this film
too okay
[Applause]
how how do you think it came out and
will you come back and talk about it and
how exciting is that I will like you and
Meg Ryan I loved it I loved Meg we I
loved working with her she was a great
director and fabulous actress to work
with so yeah I'll come back anytime
please I'm so excited
I mean you've worked with all these
great women you know Sarah Jessica
Parker did you have fun doing sex this I
did did you enjoy it as much as we
enjoyed it I don't know it's a hard it's
a hard it's hard to answer
um I feel like I'm walking into it there
uh but yeah I mean it was a while ago
and I do remember having a really nice
time and actually our our kids went to
high school together so I would see
Matthew and Sarah quite a bit and then
there's a fun fun fact about the end of
the episode that I didn't know it's well
it's it there there's a person at the
end screaming and who that I didn't know
who the person was right Michael Patrick
King it's the guy who created the show
yeah yeah
um and I don't know I don't know if he's
trying to say something or you know that
was his uh I don't know if he'd acted
before or or since but
that's him that was just such a fun fact
um okay you and Jillian Anderson
um in The X-Files is it true that like
you were the internet's first sex symbol
um
I don't know I don't know if I can say
true or false but uh at first I remember
why aren't they just interested in the
show why aren't they just interested in
in the product it's all of a sudden
they're interested in a person so there
were fan groups with specific names
weren't there yeah do you remember any
of them it was the David Duchovny
estrogen Brigade yes yeah
that's one
and I don't remember there was a dukov
Nicks well that's pretty easy yeah
that's a lot Tamer than the other one
yeah but that show was so personal for
people I mean that show was very
important to people well I think it's it
was about truth it was and it fulfills
it fulfilled something at the time that
wasn't that wasn't out there it wasn't
on TV there wasn't like a scary smart
show and it was appointment television
yeah like there was I mean it was a
phenomenon yeah and what do we believe
and what's true did people talk to you
about it though fanatically was there
like that connection of like I heard you
got fan letters and people would reach
out with their real life experiences
yeah it was it was humbling in a way
because I was I was when the show first
started you know I'd get like 15
fan mail letters a week and I thought it
was my responsibility to take them home
and
and answer them
no no
oh
and then and then as I started to read
the letter some of them were very sad
and and you know they were about you
know loneliness and and people reaching
out and and feeling that they've been
abducted and things like that I was like
I'm not quite I don't have the answers
I'm not quite here's a here's an
autographed picture
um is it true that you like Polaroids
um well I mean I used I mean I used to
have a camera yeah we used to screw with
them in a way that's interesting I think
and we have to cut to a quick commercial
break I was wondering can we take each
other's picture yeah but then we got
okay we got some coins we've got some
coins okay right perfect here we go
okay and now oh yeah
and then David's gonna take a coin and
design the Polaroids and so now this is
what all the Gen Z or the Millennials
it's been 30 years and yet you're
rocking it
[Music]